okay I have a clip for you today that is
notable not only for its absurdity and
its stupidity as much as it's notable
for its truly xenophobic basis when you
listen to what it is that tucker carlson
said on his show the other day in
dismissing the idea that russia
interfered in the 2016 election even
though they did even though the Moller
report makes that clear even though our
intelligence agencies all found that
Russia interfered tucker carlson
did something sort of slick I'll admit
it sort of slick sort of ignorant and
it's very xenophobic but it is a little
bit slick he said that the real election
interference is Mexican people who
legally became citizens of the United
States and then voted as is their right
of citizenship it's as ridiculous as it
sounds I'm gonna play a clip for you
where Tucker Carlson is apparently
arguing that everything Russia did for
which we have endless evidence is not
interference in an election but that
Mexican people who come here legally
become citizens and then choose to vote
is a form of interference now you've got
to listen really carefully to the words
that are used and what tucker carlson
says here take a look well if you watch
Robert Muller speak this morning at
11:00 you heard him echo the view of
official Washington that Russia had a
major effect on the 2016 election well
as we've noted before that is an absurd
claim there is zero evidence that it's
true none that Robert Muller himself has
presented but if you're looking for
countries that really do influence
American politics there are quite a few
anyone who lives in DC can tell you that
Russia does not make the list Mexico
definitely does at the beginning of the
past presidential election cycle for
example Mexico began what Bloomberg News
described as an unprecedented effort to
get American citizenship for its
permanent residents living here in the
US the point was obvious of course to
make them voters so they could vote to
defeat Donald Trump Russia never even
considered election hacking that bold
tucker is suggesting here that mexicans
who meet the requirements to become
citizens and become citizens and then
choose to vote are committing a type of
interference in the hola
action that is actually interference
unlike what Russia did in 2016 number
one citizens voting is not interference
in an election it's called the election
process right when people are citizens
and they vote that is not a way to
interfere with the election it is a way
to participate in the election the
definition of interference is the action
of interfering or the process of being
interfered with when American citizens
vote it's not interfering with the
election process it's the election
process when Russia medals accesses
voting systems helps one candidate get
dirt on another runs social media
campaigns and trolling campaigns and
fake news campaigns and disinformation
campaigns online that is not a main
election process those are actions that
are interfering with the election when
you get beyond that you realize that
this is fundamentally xenophobic because
the underlying motivation or implication
here is that well yeah of course
citizens get to vote here but when it's
brown people from Mexico who obtain
citizenship through naturalization it's
not really part of the democratic
process it's an interference with the
democratic process now from a logistical
standpoint can you imagine this as a
strategy to affect election results by
Mexico you're counting on people from
Mexico coming to the United States
legally living here long enough to
qualify to apply for citizenship
applying for citizenship paying all of
the associated costs eventually getting
that citizenship all to vote in
elections legally as a means to affect
elections it would be an incredibly
stupid and inefficient way to try to
affect the election results in the
United States and if you believe that
you would probably believe the idea as
many trumpets do that Barack Obama was
part of a conspiracy that dates back to
his birth to get a foreigner to be
President of the United States some kind
of shadowy entity that I guess 45 years
before Barack Obama became president
faked a birth certificate to make sure
that a foreign-born dude would be
president in
and eight in the United States they
faked his parents they faked the birth
certificate who knows what the latest
version of that conspiracy is if you
believe that then I guess maybe you
would believe that Mexicans having the
long-term plan of becoming legal
citizens in order to vote is a way to
interfere and affect elections any
normal sensible rational person would
realize the absurdity of it and as part
of this kind of long game idea you don't
actually need to go to that Mexican
conspiracy to understand the long game
that Russia has been playing I mean go
back to the 1997 book foundations of
geopolitics by Alexander Dugan and you
will see that everything Russia has been
doing in the United States and elsewhere
for the last several years was written
out and suggested as a strategy for
sowing geopolitical chaos to Russia's
advantage more than 20 years ago in the
book foundations of geopolitics but
listen this is if you were in Tucker
Carlson's core fox news audience you
probably hear this idea of Mexicans are
interfering by legally becoming citizens
and voting it's probably a great fit for
you and it's probably the type of stuff
that makes dr. Carlson have those solid
ratings on Fox News disgusting
absolutely disgusting but I understand
why Tucker Carlson saying it because his
audience is eating it up like it's being
spoon-fed to them